le deuxième poncifs lac est vraiment en
2022 faut arrêter avec la consommation
d'énergie de bitcoin non seulement cette
consommation n'est pas grave mais elle
est extrêmement positive
j'explique
cette industrie qui est toujours dénoncé
comme une catastrophe écologique en fait
c'est l'industrie
intensive qui a fait le plus rock le
plus rapidement sa transition verte en
2000 2015 quand j'ai commencé moi on
était à peu près à 25% d'énergies vertes
utilisées pour le meeting de bitcoin
aujourd'hui c'est 60% et ses 60% surplus
du renouvelable c'est à dire que dans le
monde vous avez énormément de puissance
électrique de disponible qui n'est pas
utilisé et sur le durable agente en a
sur l'hydroélectricité la géothermie et
les classiques les éoliennes les eau
légère traditionnels est donc
accusé bitcoin de deux
d'être un problème écologique c'est
juste une méconnaissance totale de
commencer un travail nous les mineurs on
achète le kilowatt elle ment pas cher
que les compagnies d'électricité n'ont
aucun intérêt à nous la vendre à nous si
la bande à quelqu'un on est un acheteur
de dernier recours je vois ma dame qui
dit non mais malheureusement c'est mon
métier donc moi le marché électrique
mondiale je le connais très très bien
aujourd'hui je peux vous mettre sur la
table des centaines et des centaines de
mégawatts qui sont inutilisés et sénat
examine c'est pas en france ou en
allemagne où on a un réseau de
d'électricité qui est très bien
distribués c'est dans les endroits où on
est en train de développer des nerfs et
a énormément de capacité de puissance
installée qui seront utilisés
[Musique]